5 26 on your wednesday morning hey meet  that guy who put up that please fix the  road sign on ford apache in the far  southwest valley  and find out what the county  commissioner who serves that area had to  say to him  we reported monday on the county's  completion of the project that started  back in january  [Applause]  with blasting some of the terrain south  of warm springs down towards wigwam hey  county commissioner justin jones what  all did the county put in there two  vehicle lanes both ways buffered bike  lanes sidewalks and street lights at the  ceremony marking the end of the work  jones had a few words for ed benitez the  fella that made that fix this road sign  we got a new sign for you  there you go  so the county is now planning to extend  those improvements on fort apache all  the way south to blue diamond buckle up  drive carefully please put down the  phone join the driving you crazy  conversation at traffic 8 8newsnow.com